want to see a tangible way that brain
training can improve your performance in
the gym in competition and in life train
psychomotive vigilance psychomotive
vigilance is your ability to maintain
cognitive function under load stress or
fatigue think of a fighter who's already
gone five rounds their vision is blurred
they feel tired the fight has gone from
their eyes and their reactions are slow
if their opponent is still sharp they've
lost the fight at this point likewise
think about a surgeon after a long shift
or anybody getting behind the wheel for
a long drive after a stressful day
functional coaches like luminary and
friend of the channel Jason Santana make
this a priority when training their
athletes so how do you train this a
common option is with pre-fatigue
pre-fatigue yourself with metabolic
conditioning and then follow that up
immediately with sparring juggling or
other drills that require concentration
this can serve as your active recovery
during a hit session in fact stay alert
bye for now